on poursuit avec notre série avoir 20
ans consacrés aux jeunes de la
génération 2022 rencontre aujourd'hui
avec codor un rappeur originaire de
dijon il nous ouvre les portes de son
studio pour nous parler de son parcours
bamba guèye et sylvain billau l'ont
rencontré
c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans c'est tout
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle codor j'ai 22 ans
et je suis rapport à mes heures perdues
j'habite à dijon c'est kauder
[Musique]
c'était apps et c'est l'étape finale le
mixage parce que y'a sélectionner une
instru et l'écriture l'enregistrement
est ensuite le mix info le bol
[Musique]
l'écriture c'est là où je prends le plus
de plaisir c'est un exutoire quant à des
choses à raconter quand tu veux faire
passer des messages
mais mon père y connaît un minimum les
vis de ce milieu là ça veut dire qu'il a
refusé que toute personne ne s'y nouent
toute personne me produise donc il sait
me mais c'est évidemment dans la
production et c'est lui qui investit
qu'investit sur moi on a salué c'est
devenu mon producteur personne mcdp est
donc je me sers moi dans la caisse les
yeux cernés beaucoup m'ont tourné le dos
alors qu'on s'était prêté serment on
peut parler d'un livre tu dois parler de
mon côté je peux parler de ce que tu es
faut savoir la musique c'était déjà
super saut j'ai deux petites soeurs je
fais attention à cette fille le groupe
premier texte que j'ai écrit j'ai 8 ans
j'ai commencé à lire des poèmes et
poésie tu vois ça me dit j'ai eu est le
premier sont que j'ai enregistrées sur
une instru j'avais 8 ans et demi
selon mme oka l'équipe faisaient toinon
semaine
tu dois motorola de 20
ici on est au 24 rue ernest renan
20300 chenôve c'est ici où je suis né
c'était ma première demeure ici au
troisième étage
quand j'étais petit j'écoutais beaucoup
les artistes émergents comme rohff la
fouine
booba tous ces artistes là qu'on a tous
écouté mais en grandissant
je me suis j'ai un peu élargie cette
cette culture musicale la j'écoutais
beaucoup de variété française
j'écoute du monsieur du rap américain du
rap nigérien jeu j'essaie de
m'intéresser à tous
j'ai collaboré avec les youtuber que
tout le monde connaît mes choix et mac
stagnent sur un titre avec babacar on a
fait ma commune ça a été un beau
tremplin pour moi ça m'a servi ça m'a
servi avec une sacrée expérience il
faut savoir que c'est dans la musique
qui à certains artistes qui qui servent
d'une image qui joue un rôle pour la
musique moi sincèrement je suis en toute
authenticité ça veut dire que coderre
déjà effectué un typique je me suis dit
qu en plus de ça sa portée
c'est apporter un côté authentique
dans chaque coin l'élu il ya des gens
qui font de la musique à des gens qui
des gens qui sont pas sur l'ir ça ça
veut dire qu'il ya toujours quelqu'un
qui va arriver un autre qui va aller aux
oubliettes samedi il faut toujours être
présent fait omniprésent sur les réseaux
sur sur les plateformes et c'est
important
on avait
[Musique]
y a du bon
l'ag du 25 mai la gauche
l'avis de man a souhaité que les états
elle avait mal à cheval on est devant le
lycée montchapet c'est là où j'ai fais
tout toute ma scolarité lycée c'est là
où j'ai passé le bac franchement ça fait
plaisir de revenir ici certains moments
je suis parvenu déjà je rappelle je
faisais des petits freestyle le lycée
j'avais déjà ce côté musique dans ma
petite vie là bas il ya le bâtiment des
landes tu vois on se rejoignait temps en
temps là bas on faisait des freestyles
on écrivait mais c'était l'école avant
tout c'était l'année du bac mais j'étais
à fond dans mes études j'étais à fond
dans ce que je faisais mais y avait là
il y avait la musique les gens il savait
que je faisais un petit peu de musique
[Musique]
dans 20 ans je vais avoir une vie
normale je vois ce que je veux dire ce
soit par la musique si je réussis à
faire quelque chose ou par le travail
parce qu'il faut savoir que la musique
c'est que de la musique il faut
travailler faut avoir un pied à terre
faut juste avoir une ligne directrice à
voir ce qu'on vous ait
tu peux être bon
m
[Musique]